the senate is expected to meet this
morning in a rare saturday session to
work on the roughly one
trillion dollar infrastructure bill 16
republicans joined democrats to begin
debating the bill on friday
in the latest show of bipartisan support
for the measure
it's a big victory for the biden
administration but one that comes with
many battles ahead
christina raffini has the latest from
the white house christina good morning
good morning elaine you know we've been
talking about this bill so long i'm
almost out of infrastructure
puns but as you mentioned this morning
the legislation is trucking along the
senate is here to hammer out the details
of what is already looking to be about a
2500 page
piece of legislation
we're not done yet but we're going to
get this baby across the finish line
the current version of the one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill comes after
months of bipartisan
and sometimes partisan back and forth
what we vote on looks like what we've
agreed upon
it will pass motion upon reconsideration
is agreed to
looks like you reached a bipartisan
agreement on infrastructure fancy word
for bridges roads
transit systems high-speed internet
clean drinking water
two-thirds of the senate voted to start
debate on the measure wednesday
a sign that the legislation will have
enough support to pass
but a vote in the house is less certain
we need to
be transformative in terms of how we go
forward with infrastructure investments
and reconciliation bills that truly meet
families needs
speaker of the house nancy pelosi has
said she won't take up the
infrastructure bill
unless the senate also passes a separate
3.5
trillion dollar budget plan that would
require the vote of every single
democrat in the senate
but arizona's kristen cinema has already
signaled she has a problem with the
price tag
how do we let it get this bad you know i
think a lot of it was politics
secretary of transportation pete
buttigieg told michelle
there's no time to waste the roads and
bridges the ports and airports
so many elements of the transportation
infrastructure in this country
need work we've been failing to invest
for decades
it's catching up to us now
now lawmakers say it's going to be a
grind but they're hoping they can have
something to vote on in the next couple
days
and michelle also overnight the the
federal eviction moratorium
expired and that was to help people who
fell behind on their rent due to covid
house democrats just didn't have the
votes to get it extended
despite pleas from president biden and
that's going to affect a lot of people
christina thank you very much